hey yesterday I went the entire day
without realizing I had another pair of
my underwear in my pant leg and now I
realize I'm completely okay with the
idea of self-driving cars if I couldn't
detect half a pound of cotton slithering
around my legs pretty sure a Tesla is
gonna know to hit the brakes before I
will my reaction time was 9 hours the
most selfish thing that a human being
can possibly do is leave an empty
shopping cart in a parking space I just
hate what that says about people right
you're telling me you can meander for
two-and-a-half miles inside Costco
pushing that thing in the moment you get
to your vehicle you're like not another
step that's why I don't even care
anymore you guys can try this too
everytime I'm inside a grocery store I
take someone else's cart try it full of
food take it it's much faster and you to
try new things you can do that it isn't
wrong it's not stealing look at that he
possibly would say to you excuse me
I gathered that did you say things they
can regather you know the route that's
how I found out that I like hummus you
know what else is not stealing putting
an extra bike lock on a stranger's bike
it's pretty crazy that bike locks are
legal you have any idea the amount of
power you wield with your imagination in
a bike lock so many possibilities you
can just walk past the Baskin Robbins
and be like you're closed
so arbitrary what we need permission to
buy and what we don't you have to show
photo ID and a hobby shops to get paint
yet all of us are just one Amazon click
away from buying orange cones and making
traffic go wherever we want I have a
landline telephone I didn't buy it just
came with a tiny house that I rent in LA
I was talking to my neighbor in our
front yards recently this guy's nosey
some of us have that neighbor this guy
is open about it though it's
uncomfortable
he very casually through this and into
the dialogue hey kelan the other day I
picked up part of a conversation from
your cordless phone through my baby
monitor yeah that's a real thing that
can happen I didn't know I also didn't
know how to respond to him he's just
smiling like a weirdo so I said actually
I don't have a cordless phone oh but
occasionally I do stand in your baby's
room and talk to him
that's probably what that was anything
else no this guy was telling me about
that movie the revenant I haven't seen
it I probably will I just didn't agree
with his reason for encouraging me to
watch it he said you've got to see it
for Leonardo DiCaprio I think it's great
he finally won an Oscar for that movie
because he worked really hard on it they
shot it for nine months in the
blistering cold he walked through those
rivers himself he lost 35 pounds during
those nine months isn't that amazing and
I said if you think that's amazing you
severely underestimate what I would do
for 20 million dollars that makes no
sense there's not a person here who
wouldn't do everything he had for that
paycheck right look if he acted well
great
give him the Oscar for that reason but
not just because he worked for almost a
year 20 million dollars he lost 35
pounds I would get down to 35
[Applause]
you